thank you I have pleasure to this
my basically PhD thesis which I'm
researching on Warsaw University
technology okay before I get into
technical details I'd like to explain a
few medical terms and basically the
reasons why I basically the reason why
that that problem in general is quite
important so basically what is a pretend
birth so usually a pregnancy takes like
40 weeks and all those children which
are born before 37th week classified as
a preterm delivery of preterm birth and
so far we didn't know the reasons why
it's happening and but it's very
important because it's it's causes a
different health issues in the future
life for those sweet children and few
facts about that so basically according
to WH Oh 15 million every year 50
million children are born prematurely
and about 1 million of the surgeons are
dead unfortunately and preterm birth and
put them deliver a most common case of
neonatal death despite a great
advancement in pregnancy care frequency
of preterm delivery doesn't decrease at
all and thus is very important to
develop a method which will assess the
risk of preterm delivery and what will
enable the Jenna colleges to start
intervention treatments let me just rub
this number because it's quite important
in journal I from my research so
basically half of those children will
suffer from different handicap like like
neurological one I will suffer from
delay of development and
probably heard of certain sites and
approximate 30 percent of those cases
not predicted at all
and I think is this place where greater
which we can do something regarding
prepare so matters and develop some some
approaches to so okay Karen the girls
met with basically which involved boosts
base or basically the kinematic
currently diagnosis might involve
basically two approaches which is like
collection of material characteristic by
a usual the interview by asking what is
a style of living basically is there any
issues or disease which are future
mother who suffers for and second a
produce mayor analyzes are transvaginal
ultrasound images and those are analyzes
basically is based on genealogist
knowledge and experience and you can
imagine that this is the place which is
prone to error because this kind of
subjective thing whether the ACOG was
able to detect something or not and
those are Eliza's those the others of
those images is supported quite often by
some visual features like cervical
length what is the cervical length the
basically it's it refers to the left of
the the cervix and in general are
there's like rule but it's not the
golden rule it doesn't work in all cases
during the pregnancy as cervical death
my shorten what increased the risk of
preterm labor but of course not the case
it's almost not the case that's why
we are doing - what what we would like
to improve those methods to find a
better way to to estimate pregnancy
birth as I hope you can see all those
image cervical left usually it's
estimated by by straight lines like here
you know is the one or two lies it's
quite important because I we been
fighting to that slice and then after
after in the second part of my
presentation so this is our a pirate
island our proposal in general we we
proposed a method to reduce the number
of preterm delivery by automation visual
inspection of those which was all images
and by introducing additional
biomechanical markers ACA basically it
stands for medical term it stands for
anterior cervical angle which I will
explain later and and we prove that
those two markers the CL and I see a
combined perform better than and current
diagnosis method and will and can be
useful even for prediction preterm birth
before 34th four weeks of pregnancy
which is very important because before
that time is very crucial week because
before that a lot of children which are
born basically will die so first dataset
we collected almost reached three 350
360 ultrasound images as you can see our
dataset is not so from so much so big
the reason is because it requires that
genic illegal gene ecologist assess to
to basically obtain that is not so easy
and the basically time-consuming task
however we we argument at our data set
to 6,000 images by applying around
rotation in the range of minus 10 to 10
degrees applies some random contrast and
brightness these are few examples of our
data set in general Luke is very similar
about trust me there are not next step I
call it's like a pre-processing
it contains a few parts like annotation
tool and image paging start of an
annotation tool we develop a tool in
order to allow the genie colleges to
apply markers in a much much accurate
way so for instance instead of like
estimation those Sarika life either as I
showed you before by one or two straight
lines we can do it by like applying
Bezier curve example let me show you on
the video so after uploading that USD
image able to like a draw on that image
like a curve and edit those points to
make it more accurate so this is our
example before I kind of edgy like in
each and this one is exported after
exported from annotation tool so so
instead of a straight line we have here
basic curve which is tomato by the way
the length of the cervix here is another
it's basically a part of those entree or
a cervical angle which I was referring
to and and yeah we use those images a
formalization tool as a grant through
the ground through to two segmentation
tasks which I will talk in like two
minutes and a lot of stuff is image in
painting basically what is in painting
doesn't ever know nope
in painting in general in general is its
algorithm
which is used to reconstruct a lost part
of images or videos and in our approach
we would like to use that to avoid that
situation when our neural network wished
our start recognized the the cervical
based on that markers we don't need that
basically it's an it's the markers are
advanced to in order to find a cervical
in order to receive to obtain a better
better result we like we apply some
let's say tweaks to that that images to
and fears of a visual of those freaks
like is translate from RGB color space
to eat is V and this way we were able to
quite easily define the color space
which like to get rid of those images in
our case it was like few shades of
yellow then we apply method called very
short fat Trel holding which basically
were able to get a binary mask and and
after that we use the method called
dilation which is responsible for
expanded mask a little bit to get rid of
pixel which are neighborhood from that
markers so this is the mask below that
mask and that image was the input to in
painting conquer it and the result here
is this is the worst case which we
obtained so this is the input image and
this is the same image without that
marker hopefully there is you can see
the difference okay next step is
segmentation as you can notice
you can notice that we use a unit at
work
[Music]
we just used because basically designed
to analyzes biomechanical images in
general and is performing pretty good in
terms of segmenting images especially
and few words about the units units
basically contains two similar parts the
left part is responsible for finding
features the the right part is
responsible for segmentation and
localizing those features on the image
so our goal was to train that network in
the order that to achieve that that
binary mask which showed us where the
cervical is on that input mask input
image story so we use intersection of a
union as a relation metric because it is
basically it's quite useful metric in
terms of finding finding mask and
finding patterns and the image so it's
easy to rather to you understand that
when that metric is close to zero
basically means that you approach
doesn't order at all but in case where
is close to one or even equals one is
that you find a perfect match was the so
during training we were able to obtain
intersector of almost ninety one percent
zero one zero zero to ninety one so i so
I think is pretty good results basically
we were training hours data over the
network about three days
this is the very results and from the
top to the bottom so at the bottom there
is input images after in painting so
without those markers in the middle
there are ground through mask obtained
from annotation tool and the bottom
there's a result Geritol pad unit next
step is estimation those two parameters
but before I go to the electric spindle
sorry
that is fine so next episode summation
so we use that obtained cervical mask
and try to apply to a centre line
algorithm there was a few matters that I
do this algorithm basically usually the
result quite common one based on spying
3 and Voronoi algorithm so basically
there rule is like having like a data
set of points is able to find out like
the place in the middle of that blood
pumped it's pretty pretty like basic
algorithm but it's personal preference
really where we will agree well and in
our our approach this image is very
important because it shows that
correlation between our results and the
ground through
Sarika length is close to 1 so we are
basically can sell say that we can use
estimators vehicle length and a medical
rescue diagnostic already a treatment
without let's say general ecology
ecology just assists and about
intelligence rekha angle so this is the
marker which like to introduce basically
we did not invent it at like because it
was exist like for decades but it wasn't
taking
in workouts seriously and and we proved
that that marker is performed really
where I combined into the cervical
length so what does the meaning in
general and basically the angle between
our end of the cervix is here more or
less and part of uterus called entire
wall which is here that's it
of course you can find the places where
is it
and that part is in progress we are
trying to find a best best approach to
to measure that angle that image is
basically what it represented like on
the shape to the cervix
we applied three different center line
algorithm with some modifications in
order to obtain the best result in a
measurement of the angle as I said a
single progress will because result is
not so good as as we like to like to as
we expected but we are close to to
finish it right now so sooner probably
will be able to - to present for the
results and the most important path
present prediction because this is
explanation why we're doing it at all so
having those obtained estimations
cervical life estimation and those and
measure those angles this time by a by
geologists and we evaluate a simple
chemical classification algorithm in
order to assign preterm versus control
able to the input ultrasound images and
we use the knife bias classification
which stratified cross-validation twenty
five to twenty five and we build one
hundred times
and results her next so in general I
like to explain what is receive
operation operating characteristics does
anybody know what doesn't mean I mean is
there any ok you guys so in general that
those characteristics
basically show how your classification
is performing is quite often used in a
medical medical our classification and
predict medical diagnosis and what is
important here area under that curve
basically the square is equal a
probability of in our case detect
preterm having those two parameters and
we are performed three scenarios so I
think they probably is not readable so
the field line is at first we try to
predict using only cervical length as a
blue color here then we try to predict
us predict president delivery you think
only Ontario Celica angle as a parameter
so this is a yellow line here and at the
end we try to do the same using those
two parameters combined and this is the
Green Line story and here the result for
first week on earth we obtain as twenty
seventy percent accuracy for a CA we
obtain seventy-six slightly worse but
for Dewsbury combined we obtained 84
percent specific a ten percent better
than the method which the basal cervical
length and basically all the current
methods based on those cervical health
we speed those speed those snares on the
first and second trimester and we obtain
a bit even better result for second
semester so basically for for cervical F
and at area silica angle were playing
pretty same result as before but for
tourists where they combined we obtain
85% of accuracy so 50 or 30 things if
you were somebody about the team and in
that project physically that project
operation between Warsaw University
ecology medical university Awards way
King's College of London and the team
basic contains basically there's a few
six person five engineers at one MD it
was involved well project and those are
plans which I like to focus in the near
future
so basically finish though safe
implantation of a CA parameters and in
order to make it automatically bye-bye
segmentation basically I mean I guess
that's most important for to verify
although our approach supply to
different datasets basically four
different countries and different you
know ages as well and the plans are that
we would like to try to that approach on
different medical markers not only
focusing on Britain delivery but in
general can you thank you very much
attention I guess we have couple minutes
for questions yes we did
some questions okay so in case you try
to predict markers this QC is possible -
just to make it end to end even at the
cost of being a black box
so we tried our approach but it didn't
work
basically like there's a few issues
regarding like combining basically
trying unit in order to predict you know
and segmenting those markers it's not so
so easy to do because our proposed that
was our fuse approach it isn't work I
mean in it work but not so much as that
one okay thank you
one question oh yeah this one so once
you get the masks which come from unit
have you used any kind of
post-processing of this mask or have
used their own masks which you obtain
from their models are wrong mask without
we have of course that you know in mind
in case of obtained worse results but
you'd be surprised it went quite well so
you didn't do it alright thank you so
much thank you big round of applause
please
[Applause]